money can't quit go young inch or more
in term or you may have enough EDP bring
that arm up for the right angle
[Music]
watch your body mechanics watch your
stats you just twisted your hips
little out of place
get off the wrist right hey
it's not gonna work on bigger place now
get your body where'd it go
hey don't stand there like that that's a
that's a fail let's go let's go let's
start again can't be like anything - I
walked right goodnight church is a good
thing get over this hop of his arm over
the top or your fingers over the top for
them over the top down no more down
throw from there get your feet on the
drum face
if yours can be alive that's good
watch how you twist your stance yeah now
staying up you're switching the next
life
[Music]
hey you know you don't have your pain
again your weights too far out
darn hand fell at the hand drop fall in
the arm Rocio
[Music]
Hey
so I'm going to talk as we go okay whoa
so that foot I feel that foot that's the
water pressure let's see that if I go
this way
no it's gonna find his hand right if I
so if I try to turn him around it's not
really taking his face this is going to
go straight yeah he's got a lot of
strength there so I can force that down
but I'm doing G was there right so I
don't go going around with energy boom
[Music]
always going around this energy
always having sound body mechanics you
see for alignment
does there need to move fast tithing in
[Music]
horse Christ on service now do you
cook you up yeah
[Music]
remember on your this is all you God do
that if you want once you're going to
always go to the inside you also can
just making this you don't just have
this
day let's get the party
and you can't take turns
turn my turn no yep boom boom go you met
her in more you wouldn't hit your fist
rather then you hit her face you gotta
let her in I'm gonna do this go look up
you go this is my tummy they play with
the angle hey you see the difference
this is easy as it's gonna get a little
your line okay you see how and then you
hit me I don't care if he hits me
especially in training we get it that
was my point is wrist wrist now okay
you're gonna get hit in the fight so you
boom you should take that kinda stuff
do you understand so when you go like
this that's that we're gonna work so I'm
just here he you see I'm playing with
that angle then you're gonna see D it is
to stick inside you see my mind
connection so punch straight please
straight again straight that's what I
want
hmm okay here not here hey hey try it
right what a straight line you want that
we don't want that one straight line
there tea pot should be like this it's
not attractive missile okay
your few punches sir hmm you see that
and so he moves out of the way it should
still be there shouldn't be so much it
go
[Music]
so big too much space your top toys
straight you want to hurt it turned it
if you can't do the attempt will shake
down in the class you'll do you'll be
doing push-ups a little class stretch
this is where discipline comes in
[Music]
so when I show you the inside I'm not
cool like this hmm
right I'm going like this and my hand is
just following me you see the Sun you're
going in he's missing you turning boom
behind you'd be on the inside oh I could
be on the outside boom go have it right
here okay all right yeah get as much as
possible
whoa look how far you were better
enter smooth it out get rid of that
unnecessary fog same thing do it again
stay close enter yeah there you go good
yes possible good yeah good timing
[Music]
good Shawn a little corner
you let her freak she's freaking out see
she let her freak you out doesn't matter
if she hits you she's got a Hellfire
missile you got to punch straight just
let it hit you
these curves turns like that there's no
power which you got to try to enter go
through the punch better
well is it Zombieland you're just gonna
get shot with tranquilizer darts all
over good there you go
two moose you don't have time for two
moves too far away yeah good
[Music]
good that's it Chris keep the body alive
then don't take advantage of his size
[Music]
now you went limp again